i'm back
oh my hair
really
you ruined my groove
i'm gonna do that again
hello reject nation my name is sally
sally lamonico aka salamander if you're
an og you might remember me on the
channel from many many moons ago if not
hello i was just talking to greg and
revealed a deep dark secret to him that
i actually have not seen most of the mcu
movies i know i know it's horrible but
for once my procrastination has paid off
because i came up with a great i well we
came up with i came up with a great idea
that we would watch the marvel movies
together on this channel phases one
through four so i have seen many of them
but i saw them like right when they came
out and to be honest i don't
really remember plot very well from a
lot of these movies and i don't really
remember many details i remember
enjoying them i just didn't retain a lot
of that information i'm going to rewatch
the ones that i have seen and then
you'll be able to see my fresh reactions
seeing them for the second time and then
seeing a lot of them for the first time
i've not seen endgame i've not seen
infinity war can't wait to watch those
with you guys but we're going to go in
order that way it's the full dramatic
effect so it's going to be a great time
please hit that notification bell if you
want to be up to date on when i'm going
to be posting i am planning on posting
on this channel once a week and we are
going to go through all of them until
the very end also if you enjoyed this
video if i make you laugh if you like
looking at me i don't know please give a
like on the video because it does help
the algorithm and helps keep this
channel alive also obviously this video
is edited this is not the full reaction
to the full movie if you want to watch
the movie with me completely unedited
sit down grab a bull popcorn and see my
full reaction to everything you can
watch the full reaction on the real
rejects patreon just go to patreon.com
the real rejects so check it out lastly
thanks to prepper for editing together
these highlights for the channel y'all
are a real one if i say anything
embarrassing please cut it out i'm going
to be calling this segment the marvel
movie marathon say that five times fast
marvel movie marathon marvel movies
sally sells seashells by the seashore
see i can say that one for the first mcu
movie we are watching together we are
starting off with a bang iron man let
phase one
begin
i feel like you're driving in a court
martial this is crazy what did i do
hey forest we can talk sir oh
i see so it's personal no you intimidate
them good god you're a woman
i mean i'd apologize but isn't that what
we're going for here i thought i'd use a
soldier first i'm an airman but you have
actually excellent bone structure there
i'm kind of
having a hard time not looking at you
now is that weird
he got me flustered
if i take a picture with you
yes
it's very cool i don't want to see this
on your myspace page
please no gang signs
oh that dates this
myspace
dude i would down that whiskey
[Music]
that is starting out way darker than i
thought it would
today tony stark has changed the face of
the weapons industry by ensuring freedom
and protecting america and her interests
around the globe is he supposed to be
like a hotter version of elon musk
ladies and gentlemen it is my honor to
present this year's apogee award to mr
tony stark
tell me you get shot tony it's okay
well i'm not tony stark
but if i were tony
i would tell you how honored i feel
render on to caesar that which is
caesar's there you go
do you plan to report on the millions
we've saved by advancing medical
technology or kept from starvation with
our intellicrops all those breakthroughs
military funding honey you ever lose an
hour sleep your whole life be prepared
to lose a few with you
this is a disney movie
is that malibu looks like malibu
[Music]
yes let's go it's malibu represent
after all these years tony still has you
picking up the dry cleaning
i do anything and everything that mr
shark requires
including occasionally taking out the
trash
will that be all
yo
shots fired the mit commencement is in
june please don't harangue about this
stuff they're harassing you so i'm gonna
say yes deflect and absorb it don't i
need you to sign this before what are
you trying to get rid of before we got
plans for you as a matter of fact they
do i don't like it when you're up oh
he's jealous come on get yourself
something nice for me i already did and
oh it was very nice
very tasteful
thank you mr stark
your welcome responsible
that sexual tension is great it would be
irresponsible not to drink i'm just
talking about a nightcap hot sake yes
too please no just i'm not drinking i
don't want any
if that's what i'm talking
yes
for your consideration the jericho
i'll be throwing one of these in with
every purchase of 500 million or more
it's a piece oh nice
[Music]
ah that
is an electromagnet
hooked up to a car battery
and it's keeping the shrapnel from
entering your heart
ah let me that makes you feel uncomfy it
says for you to start working
immediately and when you're done
it will set you free
yeah right yeah
that's palladium 0.15 grams
we need at least 1.6 i wanted to go
break down the other 11.
careful
careful we only got one shot of this i
have steady hands
why do you think you're still alive huh
yeah how do you not get anxious building
a bomb in a cave
a suit
the iron giant
wrong movie
he's like that's not a bomb
jericho
[Music]
i'm surprised i don't have any of the
other guys like actually in the room
with him but i guess that would
defeat this whole
purpose
he's speaking hungarian i don't speak
hungarian okay
what do you know
open it i dare you
they're coming
he's gonna die isn't he
[Music]
surprise
that must be heavy
[Music]
oh that would hurt so bad
[Music]
oh
that sound
watch out
how do you miss he's like right there
my turn
yeah
everything's gonna explode what are you
doing
[Music]
what an idiot
yeah let's shoot at explosives
it's gotta be like cooking him how is he
not burning
[Music]
happy fourth of july
[Music]
not bad
imagine they just flew by
she was worried take us to the hospital
no he's happy no
tony no you have to go to the hospital
captivity for three months three months
effective immediately i am shutting down
the weapons manufacturer division
international as i can decide what the
future of this company will be what
direction it should take one that i'm
comfortable with and is consistent with
the highest good
for this country as well good for him
we're a team do you understand there's
nothing we can't do
if we stick together like your father
and i
i'm sorry i didn't give you a heads up
okay but if i had tony we can't eat no
more then you would have said no
so just gently lift okay
[Music]
okay uh i don't think that i'm qualified
to do this you're fine you are the most
capable qualified
trustworthy person i've ever met
should she be putting her ring in there
it smells yeah it does
the copper wire
the copper where you got it i got it
okay you got it they didn't need to add
sound effects okay now make sure that
when you pull it out you don't pull out
that doesn't matter at the end of it
that was it what's wrong uh not that i'm
just going into cardiac arrest because
you yank i thought you said this was
safe
we gotta hurry take this take this
he's so calm
it's gonna be okay okay put it in stop
talking he's dying like shut up
are you okay yeah i feel great
you okay
he's gonna have to get her therapy
ever ever ever ask me to do anything
like that ever again
i don't have anyone
that made me emotional
of course he didn't die
that was good framing i liked that and
three
two
one
that's so cool
for lack of a better option dummy is
still on fire safety if you douse me
again and i'm not on fire i'm donating
you to city college
all right nice and easy
seriously
don't do it in the room with your nice
cars bro
in three two one
okay please don't follow me around with
it either because i feel like i'm gonna
catch on fire spontaneous
okay this is where i don't want to be
jarvis you there that's your service uh
engage heads-up display
check record all preferences from home
interface we'll do so
[Music]
that's sick i love the silver
[Music]
imagine like
going in the water and then drowning in
that thing oh my god
my anxiety could never
you're crazy
oh my god
uh
[Music]
kill power
[Music]
i knew a car would get destroyed at some
point
[Applause]
it's kind of insulting but also is sweet
connect to the cisco have it reconfigure
the shell metals use the gold titanium
alloy from the sarah from tactical
satellite that should ensure fuselage
integrity while maintaining power to
weight ratio got it yes
got it understood all of that some claim
he's suffering from post-traumatic
stress and has been bedridden for weeks
whatever the case may be
no one expects an appearance from him
tonight
oh is he just gonna like pull up
love that
[Music]
hey tony you remember me sure don't
oh my god
stanley yeah
what's the world coming to him you guys
got to crash
oh my god look at you
geez
hey what a surprise
surprise [ __ ] you look fantastic
i didn't recognize you what are you
doing here she's avoiding government are
you by yourself would you get that dress
i oh it was a birthday present from you
actually
martini's extra dry extra olives extra
fast make one of them dirty
did he put 100 in there
i don't know
oh hey thanks see you here
yikes
can i at least get a reaction from you
panic
i actually almost fought at hook line
and sinker i was out of town for a
couple months in case you didn't is this
what you call accountability
if we're double dealing under the table
are we
silence is an answer guys
always remember that
recent violence has been attributed to a
group of foreign fighters referred to by
locals as the ten rings either forced to
join their militia
he's like ah
i can blow people up
yes
cover their eyes
[Music]
nice
he's all yours
nice
well i need your help right now it's
funny how that works huh yeah speaking
of funny we've got a weapons depot that
was just blown up a few clicks from
where you were being held you sure you
don't have any tech in that area i
should know about nope
this isn't a game you do not send
civilian equipment into my active war
zone you understand that this is not a
piece of equipment
he's a superhero
be gentle it's my first time
i designed this to come off so
hey
what's going on here
let's face it this is not the worst
thing you've got me doing
are those bullet holes
of course
this is only a first crude effort a man
with a dozen of these can rule all of
asia
i will give you these designs as a gift
i hope you'll repay me with a gift of
iron soldiers
come on
don't worry it'll only last for 15
minutes all right let's finish up here
it's just weird seeing jeff bridges
as a villain i keep thinking of the big
lebowski
sector 16.
she figured it out oh
hey dude
the dude is here
to kill i know
what you're going through pepper
like literally or metaphorically
you are a very rare woman
tony doesn't know how lucky he is
creep better get back there
that was stressful tony stark was able
to build this in a cave
with a box of scraps
i'm not tony stark
oh no
ah tony
when i uh ordered a hit on
you i'm worried that i was here comes
the villain speech
killing the golden goose no no no
okay where's tony now i don't know he's
not answering his phone
please go over there and make sure
everything's okay
didn't he say it lasted like 15 minutes
how is he walking how is he alive
she's fine she's with five agents
they're about to rest over that
that's not gonna be enough
my key's not working it's not opening
the door
oh wow what's that it's like a little
device it's like a thing that's gonna
pick the lock
that's the coolest thing i've ever seen
not bad huh
let's do it
[Music]
damn
of course she's in heels
ah
how are you running with heels on the
grated floor oh my god pepper
tony tony are you okay i'm fine
oh but he's he's got insane
what the
[Music]
girl you better keep running in those
hills
[Applause]
oh my god
[Applause]
it's like
transformers for 30 years
he's gonna freeze them
my suit is more advanced in every way
how'd you solve the icing problem icing
problem
you might want to look into it
we are now running on emergency backup
power
are you okay i'm almost out of power i
gotta get out of this thing i'll be
right there
how did you not die oh my god
oh
this looks important
i never had a taste for this sort of
thing but i must admit
i'm deeply enjoying the suit it's ready
tony get off the roof
oh
trying to read the world of weapons
you gave me the best one ever
pepper
and now
i'm gonna kill you with it i had no idea
[Music]
uh how is she not dead what
you'll be hearing from us
from the strategic homeland just call a
shield
there's been speculation that i was
involved in the events that occurred the
freeway and the rooftops i'm sorry mr
stark but do you honestly expect us to
believe that that was a bodyguard in a
suit it is one thing to question the
official story and another thing
entirely to make wild accusations
truth is
i am iron man
i love how she's just sitting there like
i got stood up by iron man got it
um listen i take full responsibility for
this i
she so had a date with marvel
and uh
i did not tell her like by the way
there's a thing called post credit
scenes you should stick around for them
till the very end uh but she she's
already like moved on to the next movie
here but
yeah that's my fault why there's not a
reaction to uh the post credits it would
have been cool to see a reaction then i
know i know i know that's that's what i
should have told i should have told her
i'm sorry
that was iron man
he is iron man well i thoroughly enjoyed
that
i know this was
made in like 2008 so there's some
obvious like dated stuff about it but i
will say
i'm very pleasantly surprised by how i
feel like mature the plot was
in comparison to
other disney action movies i know this
is disney but also marvel so also
technically a little more mature with
the superhero
aspects of it i think the comic books
obviously are way more
violent and mature and so i guess i was
just shocked to see a lot of uh
mature elements in this movie but as an
adult i enjoyed it i thought it was uh
it was really entertaining i wish i had
tony stark's confidence like damn
there's something about that that got me
a little
it's a little hot in here
i love the classic like starts out as an
[ __ ] and then the character arc you
know
is blooming throughout the whole entire
film and then by the end of it the
[ __ ] is the hero it's been done a lot
but i love the way that his character
plays it because a lot of the dialogue
was very self-aware i would say because
you would like think of certain things
and you know it would kind of you would
basically think a lot of cheesy things
or you would kind of expect him to say
something based off the formula of like
other movies and dialogue and he would
kind of call it out i just thought the
dialogue between specifically between um
tony stark and pepper potts was very
fun
it was very different like i don't know
i would expect them to say something
cheesy and then it was something that
you know they they pretty much turned
that on its head which i thought was
really
really unique a breath of fresh air for
a disney movie that typically you can
kind of you know expect certain things
to happen there were parts of the plot
that were predictable but i still
enjoyed it because it seemed to be very
self-aware about it and kind of made up
for it in the dialogue i would say and a
lot of the jokes and kind of poking fun
up the genre which i think is fun and
different so i i definitely now get why
iron man
is a very popular superhero i really
like the characters i'm excited to see
this character continue to blossom into
a hero hopefully he keeps his snarky
comments because that's obviously part
of his character and i love it hopefully
him and pepper get together i don't know
it just makes me want to watch the rest
of them i thought the military elements
were very different again not really
something that i was expecting i don't
really know what i was expecting in
terms of the plot but i thought that
that was uh
like again more of a mature element to
have in a movie that is considered a
disney franchise even though it is a you
know formulaic sort of situation i still
really enjoyed a lot of the
cinematography in it it was different i
think that even for the time in 2008 a
lot of it like didn't look bad at all
there was that scene where um the
villain was like facetiming him in the
beginning but it was before iphone so it
was on his like flip phone and like it
didn't look too detailed which i thought
was great because that always bothers me
when um characters are like video
calling each other and you can tell that
it looks way too good for a video call
so i mean those sort of elements of it
like the cgi i thought was really good
it definitely
holds up in in that sense in my opinion
even though i don't i'm not like an
expert on cgi but nothing about the cgi
kind of pulled me out of it and was like
that looks bad you know so i thought
that was that was great it seems like
this was kind of just like it was a
solid movie but it seems like it's
definitely kind of a appetizer i feel
like there's definitely more to dive
into that whole
world and obviously i know there's a
show called agents of shield i haven't
watched it but i really like that that
was also introduced in this movie shield
because i know that that is a big part
of the avengers right
that's something that's kind of like
their own
company i guess so
yeah i really enjoyed watching this with
you guys again give this video a thumbs
up if you had any sort of similar
reactions that i did or if you like my
commentary on it and again head over to
the patreon
patreon.comtherealrejects if you want to
see it my full reaction don't forget to
subscribe see you guys for the next
movie